if your seven-year-old says I want to be
a girl and you have to and you say no
they'll take your kid away that's what
that bill in California is saying it's
unbelievable Tom how do you process that
affirming your kid hey I want to have
ice cream at 3am if I say no I'm not
affirming my kid you know you you're
basically have to understand that with
kids you need to put guard rails to
create great citizens gay straight
whatever they turn out to be you in
terms of Lifestyle there's guard rails
around entitlement there's guard rails
around structure and behavior and if you
consistently affirm everything then you
have no structure you have you you have
an out of control person